Rentre à la maison, ma puce.
On t'aime.
- Après 2 semaines, j'étais sûre
qu'elle ne reviendrait pas.
Et j'avais raison.
J'avais un pressentiment.
- Skylar rentre du travail.
Rachel et Shelia passent la prendre.
Elles ont dit à la police
que c'était pour fumer de l'herbe.
Skylar sort en douce,
monte dans une voiture
avec Rachel et Shelia,
et elles vont jusqu'en Pennsylvanie.
- Elles s'engagent sur une route
bordée d'arbres.
En sortant de la voiture,
elles disent avoir oublié
leur briquet, et demandent à Skylar
d'aller le chercher.
Et quand Skylar se retourne,
elles l'attaquent.
-Elles ont compté jusqu'à 3
et elles l'ont poignardée.
Le dernier mot qu'a prononcé Skylar
était "Pourquoi ?"
Car elle n'a vraiment pas compris
pourquoi elles voulaient la tuer.
Pourquoi elles l'ont tuée.
- Des jeux psychologiques
se mettent en place depuis le début,
c'est pour ça
que la relation est toxique.
C'est jouer psychologiquement
avec l'autre
pour arriver au même résultat :
posséder, dominer, détruire.
- Ça fait 9 ans que je bosse ici,
c'est la plus grosse affaire
que j'ai eue à couvrir.
- À un moment, elles réalisent
la gravité de ce qu'elles ont fait.
La situation de Rachel et Shelia,
c'est du sérieux.
Elles se retrouvent au tribunal,
menottées, en combinaison orange.
- Je suis désolée.
Je ne sais pas s'il y a
une bonne façon de m'excuser,
parce qu'il n'y a pas de mots
pour décrire la culpabilité
que je ressens chaque jour.
J'ai eu peur
et j'ai agi sans le vouloir.
Je n'ai jamais réalisé
la gravité de mes actions.
J'ai blessé la famille Neese
et ceux qui aiment Skylar.
J'ai blessé mes parents
et fait honte à ma famille.
Et j'ai blessé mon Seigneur
Jésus-Christ.
Que Dieu apporte la paix éternelle
à Skylar et la famille Neese.
Je suis désolée et je prie
chaque jour pour obtenir le pardon.
- Là, elles prennent conscience
de la situation et savent
que tout le monde les déteste.
- Rachel a assassiné ma fille
de sang-froid.
Skylar ne serait pas morte
s'il n'y avait pas eu Rachel.
Elle peut garder ses excuses,
parce qu'elles ne valent rien.
- Rachel était perturbée.
Elle voulait être la fille parfaite
d'une mère exigeante.
C'était une suiveuse.
Je pense qu'elle avait
très peu confiance en elle.
De l'autre côté, Shelia semblait
n'avoir aucun remords
pour ce qu'elle avait fait.
Ses actes semblaient
tout à fait acceptables pour elle,
mais pour un regard extérieur,
pas du tout.
- Shelia était...
pas dans le contrôle,
mais plutôt dans la manipulation.
Elle arrivait à vous convaincre
de faire des trucs qui allaient
dans son sens à elle.
Je m'appelle Shania,
je viens de Morgantown
et j'étais la meilleure amie
de Skylar.
J'ai rencontré Skylar via Shelia,
en fait.
Elles étaient vraiment très amies
et j'étais amie avec Shelia.
La famille de Shelia emmenait Skylar
partout avec elle.
Elle était avec Shelia
tous les week-ends.
Elle faisait partie de la famille.
Elles étaient comme des soeurs.
- Stop !
"You were free !"
- Je suis Daleen Berry, l'auteure
de "Pretty Little Killers",
le livre sur le meurtre
de Skylar Neese.
Shelia et Skylar
sont devenues amies en CE1.
Et elles ne se sont plus quittées
jusqu'au lycée.
En seconde,
Rachel est arrivée
d'un établissement privé,
un collège catholique.
Elles se sont retrouvées
dans la même classe
et sont devenues amies.
Shelia et Rachel
avaient de l'argent.
L'une d'elles avait une voiture.
Skylar, elle, venait d'un milieu
plus modeste
mais elle avait
une personnalité extravertie,
et tout le monde l'aimait.
Chacune apportait quelque chose
à cette amitié.
- Je m'appelle Rodney Lamp,
je suis producteur exécutif
ici, à WBOY TV,
une chaîne locale
en Virginie-Occidentale.
Star City
est une petite ville située
près de Morgantown.
C'est une ville étudiante.
La population totale,
étudiants compris,
est de soixante mille personnes,
et d'environ trente mille
sans étudiants.
C'est juste une petite ville.
- Star City, c'est tout petit.
C'est presque une banlieue
de Morgantown.
Il n'y a que quelques officiers
de police et quelques commerces.
- C'est un coin calme, tranquille.
Ici, vous avez le sentiment
que c'est le bon endroit
pour élever des enfants.
Je m'appelle Mary Neese,
je suis la mère de Skylar.
Je travaille
à l'hôpital universitaire
de Morgantown,
en Virginie-Occidentale.
Quand j'ai appris
que j'étais enceinte de Skylar,
c'était une surprise.
Je peux pas dire
que c'était un sentiment formidable.
J'étais inquiète.
Je ne savais pas si je serais
une bonne mère.
Je n'ai jamais vraiment eu
de désir d'enfant.
Mais je dois dire
qu'après la naissance,
quand une mère regarde son enfant,
ça change tout.
C'était génial.
- Skylar était très ambitieuse,
exubérante.
Comme tous les enfants,
elle débordait d'énergie.
- Je m'appelle Dave Neese,
je suis le papa de Skylar.
Je travaille dans une grande surface
et j'ai cinquante-huit ans.
Mary travaillait la journée
et moi, je gardais Skylar
à la maison.
On jouait à la dînette
et elle faisait la serveuse.
J'étais le client,
je faisais semblant de payer
et elle remplissait ma petite tasse
et je buvais.
Quand ma femme est rentrée
du travail, elle a dit :
"Vous faites quoi ? Tu bois quoi ?"
J'ai dit : "Juste de l'eau."
Et elle m'a dit :
"Tu sais que Skylar ne peut pas
atteindre pas le robinet..."
J'ai dit... "Oui...
Skylar, où as-tu trouvé cette eau ?"
Elle m'a emmené dans la salle
de bain, a pointé les toilettes
et a dit : "Là !"
J'ai dit : "Oh, mon Dieu !"
Aujourd'hui, c'est très marrant,
mais à l'époque,
ça ne m'a pas fait rire.
- Elle était une artiste en herbe,
une musicienne en herbe.
Tout ce qui lui passait par la tête
ou qu'elle voyait à la télé,
elle voulait le faire.
Elle voulait être serveuse,
esthéticienne, caissière,
enseignante, toutes ces choses
en même temps.
Plus tard, en grandissant,
elle voulait devenir avocate.
- Elle demandait à son papa :
"Je ferais une bonne avocate ?"
Et elle ne manquait pas d'arguments.
Alors je lui ai dit :
"Tu ferais une super avocate !"
- On a toutes commencé
à sortir en cachette
vers 14 ans, je dirais.
- On sortait en douce, on buvait
et on fumait de la marijuana.
On prenait des photos,
on s'amusait toute la nuit
et on revenait
avant que nos parents se réveillent.
- Elle avait déjà été attrapée
en train de fuguer.
La police l'avait ramenée
à la maison.
Ils avaient attrapé les filles
et quelques garçons
en train de faire une virée en ville
après l'heure du couvre-feu.
- Les parents de Skylar
savaient que leur fille sortait
souvent en cachette.
Ils ont peut-être manqué
de vigilance
parce qu'elle avait l'habitude
de faire ça.
La mère de Shelia
était très, très indulgente.
Elle voulait être la mère cool.
Elle laissait sa fille fumer
de l'herbe, faire la fête,
sortir avec des garçons
à un très jeune âge.
Le père de Shelia
avait des problèmes de toxicomanie.
De l'autre côté,
on a la mère de Rachel.
Patricia.
Certains lycéens m'ont dit
qu'elle était violente.
Même ses amis ont dit
qu'elle était violente avec Rachel.
Elle avait un problème d'alcoolisme.
Skylar a également eu
une vie familiale
très dysfonctionnelle.
Même si ses parents l'aimaient
et ne l'ont jamais maltraitée.
Mais ils avaient
leurs propres problèmes.
L'un de ces problèmes,
c'était leur incapacité à offrir
un foyer financièrement stable
à Skylar.
Du coup, Skylar rêvait
d'être amie avec des gens riches
qui pouvaient lui fournir
ce qu'elle n'avait pas.
- Skylar sortait en cachette
plus que nous toutes.
Presque tous les soirs en 3e.
Elle rentrait juste avant
que sa mère aille travailler.
Elle arrivait quand même à avoir
de très bonnes notes.
Je sais pas comment elle faisait !
- On pensait qu'elle avait arrêté
de faire le mur.
Mais, visiblement,
on s'était trompés.
- Shelia et Skylar étaient très
présentes sur les réseaux sociaux,
bien plus que moi.
Elles partageaient tout
sur les réseaux sociaux.
- Y a une dépendance à la machine,
au réseau très importante
chez les adolescents, parce
qu'il y a cette volonté de briller,
et c'est facile.
Donc c'est très valorisant
pour une ado qui cherche
à vivre des expériences intenses
et passionnantes.
Mais ça déshumanise aussi le lien.
Ça peut aussi faire obstruction
à la capacité d'empathie, et surtout
une sorte de détachement où
ce qui arrive à la victime
n'est plus aussi important.
- Elles partageaient toute leur vie
dessus.
Et quand elles postaient des choses,
elles se taguaient l'une et l'autre.
- Ça a l'air assez équilibré
au départ, jusqu'à ce que,
a priori, il y ait ce basculement.
- Le 21 août 2011,
il y a eu cette fête chez Rachel
où étaient Skylar, Shelia et Rachel.
- Un jour,
Skylar m'a raconté une histoire.
Elles étaient chez la mère
de Rachel, elles buvaient.
Shelia et Rachel se sont rapprochées
et Skylar était mal à l'aise.
Mais elles ne l'ont pas
laissée partir.
- Nous n'avons pas les détails
exacts, mais il est évident
que Shelia et Rachel
ont eu un rapport sexuel.
Et Skylar a été forcée
d'assister à ça.
Elle y a été forcée,
et j'insiste sur ce mot,
parce que la mère de Rachel
était dans une autre pièce
et qu'il ne fallait pas
la réveiller.
Rachel leur avait dit que sa mère
était méchante et violente.
Donc Skylar ne voulait pas
prendre de risque.
Elle les a donc vues
avoir une relation sexuelle.
Skylar a pris conscience
que Rachel et Shelia partageaient
un lien étroit exclusif.
Et ça l'a poussée
à s'énerver contre elles.
Shelia et Skylar en sont venues
à s'insulter
sur les réseaux sociaux.
- Et du coup,
Skylar a menacé de tout dévoiler.
- Au moment où Skylar a menacé
ses amies de tout balancer,
peut-être que ça répondait aussi
à un sentiment d'abandon
et d'exclusion,
où elle a été forcée aussi
d'être le témoin
de nouvelles règles amicales.
- Dans une petite ville,
les gens parlent.
II y a toutes sortes de rumeurs.
Si ça sort de l'ordinaire,
les gens vont en parler.
- Les parents de Rachel
sont très religieux
et très stricts.
S'ils avaient découvert
ce que faisait Rachel,
elle aurait eu des problèmes.
- La relation de ce trio
devient toxique quand on n'écoute
plus les besoins des autres,
quand on peut ressentir
de la culpabilité
ou une sensation
de pas être à la hauteur
sans jamais comprendre pourquoi.
Ce trio est basé aussi
sur la jalousie, la rivalité.
Donc quand il y a compétition,
on cherche qu'une chose ensuite,
c'est récupérer l'attention
de l'autre
pour être à nouveau valorisé
et gagner la compétition.
- Il est devenu évident
que des fissures se formaient
dans cette relation.
Skylar aimait Rachel.
Shelia aimait Rachel.
Rachel aimait Shelia.
Ce type de trio
ne peut jamais bien fonctionner
car c'est un chiffre impair.
Il y en a toujours une qui n'est pas
au niveau des deux autres.
- Shelia exerce une double emprise,
à la fois sur Skylar
et à la fois sur Rachel.
Elle exerce son pouvoir sur elles
en fixant les règles du jeu.
Dans la relation d'emprise,
y a plusieurs phases.
Y a ce qu'on appelle
la phase lune de miel
où on va séduire, valoriser
pour créer ensuite chez la victime
une sorte de dette.
Ensuite, y a la phase
d'emprise, où la relation
de dépendance commence.
Alberto Eiguer disait
que c'est "la conquête
du territoire psychique de l'autre".
Et là, on imagine que c'est
la conquête du territoire virtuel
et psychique, et affectif...
Enfin, tout entier, de l'autre.
La dernière phase,
c'est la destruction de l'autre
en l'empêchant de se réaliser
autrement que dans le lien
au bourreau.
- Skylar est allée à la plage
avec la famille de Shelia.
Sur le chemin du retour,
elles se sont disputées.
Quelle qu'en soit la raison,
à ce moment-là,
Shelia a dit à Rachel...
"Nous devons la tuer."
- J'ai suivi les rails
jusqu'aux villes voisines en criant.
J'ai passé des nuits entières
dans les bois, à espionner
une maison
où elle était allée à une fête.
Nous aussi, on a fait notre enquête,
croyez-moi.
- Skylar a commencé à être mise
à l'écart du groupe.
Par exemple, Shelia et Rachel
prévoyaient ce qu'elles porteraient
le lendemain
sans rien dire à Skylar.
Elles prévoyaient de faire
des choses sans Skylar,
et ça la blessait.
- À l'époque, on ne surveillait pas
du tout ses réseaux sociaux.
Plus tard, on a appris
qu'elle avait publié des messages
expliquant ce que les filles
lui faisaient
et comment elles la traitaient.
- Je pense que Skylar
voulait trouver sa place.
Elle avait deux amies, elles avaient
fait plein de choses ensemble.
Elles s'appréciaient.
Elle voulait juste
faire partie de quelque chose.
Un groupe pour s'amuser,
des amies avec qui sortir.
- Pourquoi Skylar continue
à vouloir être amie avec elles ?
Peut-être qu'elle est déjà
dans une relation d'emprise
où elle a abandonné
à sa persécutrice une partie d'elle.
Elle n'est valorisée
que dans son regard,
donc quand elle est dévalorisée,
elle n'attend que d'être
à nouveau valorisée.
Donc dès qu'elles l'invitent
à nouveau, elle les suit,
parce que c'est comme ça qu'elle va
se définir dans son identité
et qu'elle va pouvoir briller
comme elles.
- Les jours précédant
le meurtre ont été tendus.
Il n'y avait que des disputes.
- Et tout d'un coup, Skylar reçoit
ce message disant :
"Eh, allons faire la fête !"
Puis elles sont allées chercher
Skylar, et elle a disparu.
C'était un matin comme les autres.
Skylar avait un petit boulot.
Elle devait y aller l'après-midi.
Quand je rentrais,
d'habitude, elle était prête.
J'ai frappé à sa porte,
qui était fermée, j'ai dit :
"Chérie, c'est Papa.
C'est l'heure d'aller au travail."
Pas de réponse.
Alors j'ai crié : "Skylar !"
Toujours pas de réponse,
alors j'ai ouvert sa porte.
Son lit n'était pas défait,
la fenêtre de la chambre
était entrouverte comme ça.
C'est là que je me suis inquiété.
J'ai tout de suite appelé ma femme.
Elle m'a dit : "Appelle Shelia."
C'était censé être
la meilleure amie de Skylar.
Je l'ai appelée et lui ai dit :
"Tu sais où est Skylar ?"
Elle a dit :
"On a fait le mur hier soir."
"Quand lui as-tu parlé
pour la dernière fois ?"
"Cette nuit, à minuit."
Ensuite, on a regardé les images
des caméras de surveillance
et on a vu Skylar monter
dans une voiture.
À ce moment-là, on ne savait pas
à qui appartenait cette voiture.
La soi-disant amie de Skylar...
Je les appelle pourriture numéro 1
et pourriture numéro 2.
C'est ce qu'elles sont.
Pourriture numéro 1 a vu les images.
Elle savait très bien que c'était
sa voiture, mais elle n'a rien dit.
- J'ai pensé
qu'elle avait été enlevée.
- Rachel et Shelia disent
à la police :
"On a passé la soirée avec Skylar,
on était dehors à s'amuser,
"puis on l'a déposée chez elle.
"On ignore où elle est.
"C'est la dernière fois
qu'on l'a vue."
- Sa supposée meilleure amie a dit
que lorsqu'elles étaient rentrées,
elles l'avaient déposée
près de chez nous.
Skylar ne voulait pas être déposée
devant la maison pour éviter
qu'on apprenne qu'elle était encore
sortie en douce.
Deux jours après, toute la ville
savait ce qu'il s'était passé.
Je suis allée
sur les réseaux sociaux.
Certaines personnes détestent
les réseaux sociaux.
Mais moi, je peux vous dire
qu'ils nous ont été bien utiles.
L'information a circulé si vite.
Tout le monde essayait de nous aider
et de nous soutenir.
- J'ai suivi les rails
jusqu'aux villes voisines en criant.
J'ai passé des nuits entières
dans les bois, à espionner
une maison
où elle était allée à une fête.
Nous aussi, on a fait notre enquête,
croyez-moi.
- Shelia, un flic et moi sommes
montés dans une voiture de police.
Shelia a fait le soi-disant trajet
de cette nuit-là.
C'était juste un tour de la ville.
Elle a dit qu'elles l'avaient
ensuite ramenée chez elle.
Shelia était très investie
dans l'enquête.
Elle nous aidait à chercher Skylar
et faisait comme si de rien n'était.
- Shelia s'investit dans l'enquête
justement parce qu'elle est
dans la manipulation et le mensonge.
Elle jouit du plaisir de réussir
à manipuler son monde.
Elle a la sensation de diriger
en quelque sorte cette enquête
en obtenant un maximum
d'informations.
- Elles ont continué d'aller
au lycée comme si de rien n'était.
- Elles ont même été
au bal de promo.
- Shelia n'agissait pas
bizarrement.
Elle était triste,
disait que Skylar lui manquait.
Elle semblait vraiment inquiète
que Skylar ait disparu.
- Regardez ce qu'elle publiait
durant cette période.
"Skylar, rentre à la maison.
Tu nous manques.
"Quand est-ce que tu vas rentrer ?
Nous devons retrouver Skylar !"
- Shelia avait des tendances
psychopathiques,
mais difficile de dire
qu'elle était psychopathe,
parce que tous les adolescents
ont ces tendances.
- Aujourd'hui, on ne parle plus
de psychopathie,
mais de troubles
de la personnalité antisociale.
Quelqu'un qui souffre
de ce type de troubles,
c'est quelqu'un qui est avant tout
sans empathie,
qui cherche à dominer,
qui chercher à plaire à tout prix.
Et qui va d'emblée,
d'entrée de jeu installer
des relations de dépendance
et d'emprise.
Quelqu'un qui fixe
ses propres règles,
qui est particulièrement instable,
agressif.
- J'ai lu des récits d'élèves
qui avaient entendu
Rachel et Shelia parler bien avant
de ce qu'elles comptaient faire.
- Ça a commencé par une blague
en cours de sciences de seconde.
Elles cherchaient
comment se débarrasser d'un corps.
- À un moment, les policiers
ont commencé à soupçonner
ces deux filles
parce qu'elles sont les dernières
à l'avoir vue.
- Chris, l'officier de police,
est venu me voir.
Il a dit : "Dave, tu crois
"ce que racontent
les soi-disant amies de Skylar ?"
J'ai dit : "Bien sûr, pourquoi ?"
Il a dit :
"Je peux te montrer un truc ?"
Ici, c'est l'emplacement actuel
de son téléphone.
Il a été localisé
à soixante kilomètres.
Mais comment est-ce possible ?
Elle a dit qu'elle était chez elle,
mais clairement,
c'était pas le cas.
La police savait
qu'elles cachaient des choses,
parce qu'elles ont échoué
au détecteur de mensonges.
Surtout Shelia, qui en a raté deux.
La seule chose de vraie
qu'elle ait dite, c'est son nom.
- Shelia a échoué au test,
et Rachel, elle,
pour éviter d'y aller, a carrément
sauté de la voiture en marche.
- Rachel est la plus faible
des deux.
Ce n'est pas le cerveau
derrière tout ça.
- Tant que Shelia était près d'elle,
pendant l'année scolaire,
elle s'en sortait plutôt bien,
elle la gardait sous contrôle.
Mais lors des vacances de Noël,
elles ont dû se séparer.
- Un soir, ma femme parlait
avec Rachel sur l'ordinateur.
Elles s'envoyaient des messages.
- Rachel me demandait
si elle pouvait faire
quelque chose pour nous.
J'ai répondu : "Nous voulons
juste la retrouver
"pour qu'elle puisse
reposer en paix."
Et c'est un ou deux jours
après ça...
qu'elle a été internée
à l'hôpital psychiatrique.
- Ça a commencé par une dispute
entre Rachel et sa mère.
- Elle a été emmenée
à l'hôpital psychiatrique
où elle est restée plusieurs jours.
- Elle craque.
Elle ne peut plus cacher
ce qu'il s'est passé.
- Rachel semble avoir été
sous l'emprise de Shelia.
On peut imaginer que Rachel craque
à partir du moment où
Shelia l'abandonne,
en quelque sorte, et donc,
elle est face à un vide
et se retrouve face à elle-même.
Ce qui fait qu'elle se reconnecte
à des sensations plus empathiques
et humaines.
Elle sort de cette emprise
pour revenir à une réalité
et là, elle prend conscience
qu'elle a tué quelqu'un
et que y a des conséquences.
- Rachel parle à un avocat.
Elle avoue enfin ce qu'elles ont
fait, qu'elles ont tué Skylar.
- Shelia et Rachel sont passées
prendre Skylar.
Elle est sortie par la fenêtre
de sa chambre
et elle a couru vers la voiture.
- Elle accepte finalement de monter
dans la voiture
parce qu'elle a tellement été
culpabilisée
et dévalorisée que son seul moyen
de briller à nouveau,
c'est de les suivre.
- Elles partent en Pennsylvanie,
à environ cinquante kilomètres
de Morgantown.
- En sortant, elles disent
avoir oublié leur briquet.
Elles demandent à Skylar
de retourner à la voiture
le chercher.
- Entre elles, elles ont une sorte
de signal pour passer à l'action.
- Elles ont compté jusqu'à trois.
Un, deux, trois et l'ont poignardée.
Skylar essaie de s'enfuir.
Elle essaie de se défendre.
Skylar réussit à s'emparer
du couteau de Rachel
et la poignarde à la jambe.
Mais Skylar est trop faible.
Shelia et Rachel continuent
à la poignarder partout,
jusqu'à ce que Skylar meure.
- Elles la poignardent
plus de cinquante fois.
Puis elles essaient de l'enterrer,
mais le sol est trop dur.
- Elles avaient une pelle, mais
n'ont pas réussi à creuser de trou.
Alors elles ont recouvert le corps
avec des branches et d'autres trucs.
Et elles l'ont laissée sur place.
- Shelia et Rachel ont vraiment
compté jusqu'à trois,
et elles l'ont tuée.
- Ce mercredi, Rachel Shoaf,
a avoué le meurtre de Skylar Neese.
Une autre adolescente
est en garde à vue dans l'affaire.
- C'était partout à la radio.
Une autre adolescente a été arrêtée.
À ce moment-là,
je savais que c'était Shelia.
J'ai essayé de la contacter,
mais pas de réponse.
J'ai appelé la mère de Skylar
pour lui demander si Shelia
était la deuxième mise en cause.
Elle m'a dit : "Oui, c'est elle.
"Ces deux salopes sont en prison,
là où est leur place."
- Rachel les a emmenés là
où ça s'est passé
et a dit : "C'est là."
Ils ont sorti leurs chiens.
Ils ont fait
tout ce qu'ils pouvaient.
Il y a un énorme chêne
à cet endroit.
Un des chiens s'est arrêté,
il a levé la tête...
La dépouille de Skylar était là.
C'est comme ça qu'ils l'ont trouvée.
Ça faisait six mois
qu'elle était là.
Son corps était décomposé.
- Il ne restait que des os.
- Ouais, juste des os.
- J'étais sous le choc,
dévastée, j'avais le coeur brisé.
Ma meilleure amie a été tuée,
et je devais gérer ça.
Et en plus, mon autre meilleure amie
a été arrêtée pour meurtre.
Et dire que j'étais avec cette fille
pendant des années.
Comment quelqu'un peut
vous cacher ça
quand vous passez
autant de temps avec ?
- Vous avez une amie très proche,
depuis des années.
Vous la tuez.
Vous dissimulez son corps.
Vous mentez à ce sujet
pendant six mois.
Et vous postez des choses
sur les réseaux sociaux,
vous prétendez
vous inquiéter pour elle.
Vous participez même aux recherches
pour la retrouver.
Vous passez du temps
avec la famille, à les réconforter.
Comment deux jeunes adolescentes
ont-elles pu tuer leur amie ?
Ça n'a pas de sens !
- On essaie d'avancer
jour après jour.
Chaque jour, on se réveille...
- On continue à vivre.
- On essaie de vivre.
Parce qu'on n'a pas le choix.
On ne peut pas se laisser mourir.
On doit continuer à avancer.
C'est la vie.
On ne peut pas arrêter de vivre.
Beaucoup de gens le font.
Beaucoup de gens se terrent
chez eux et arrêtent tout.
On n'est pas comme ça.
On ne peut pas faire ça.
- Je n'arrive toujours pas
à croire ce meurtre.
Que du jour au lendemain,
ma vie ait tourné au cauchemar.
J'ai travaillé avec plusieurs
docteurs pour avancer.
Je fais en sorte
que ça ne m'affecte plus.
Mais je déprime quand viennent
les dates qui me rappellent Skylar.
Sous-titrage : BLUE ELEMENTS